avez vous remarqué une différence de
comportement chez votre sert depuis
votre situation professionnelle beaucoup
moyennement légèrement pas du tout
considérez vous votre part en contre
comme utile à autre chose que nous faire
chier beaucoup moyennement légèrement ou
pas du tout on trouvait un blu aussi
génial que mien mais puis cuisine
affirmé céline a fait du téléphone rose
oh oui c'est bon je suis tes opératrice
en fait de l'ombre
sonne et sa bonne nouvelle j'ai pas
envie d'aller dans cette famille
d'accueil
je fais tout pour que tu es pas on veut
un contrat de travail sous quinze jours
sur matha ou qui me sera placé sur ordre
du juge
ici c'est chez elle il y avait que ça
nous fait tout pour qu'elle s'en sorte
j'ai peut-être quelque chose à vous
propose elle c'est quoi c'est plus un
jeu pensé à quelque chose comme 200 mais
d'euros mais il ya certaines conditions
à remplir sam
tu vas pas faire ça un petit tu vas pas
faire tout paris je peux pas laisser
tomber kim oui mais ça on peut pas le
faire on n'a pas le droit c'est juste
pas légal quand j'en ai plein de culture
de la permission de faire ci ou de faire
ça
saint bernard est un terrain tout bouge
activités parce qu'elle va faire une
grosse connerie tu dis je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime je suis complètement
raide dingue de toi est ce que tu mettes
ma femme est ce que tu fais des gosses
combien tu veux te voir quelle couleur
tu quittes pour mauvaise passe [ __ ]
comment elle parle vite celle là et
mademoiselle tu veux faire incroyable
talent mon fère s'est toujours choisi
bien ce que tu veux faire ma vie parce
que ça va marcher samedi n'ya pas me
bitton bien avant qu'ils vont vous
regardez en clignant des couilles mais
c'est ce truc là qui va pas on dirait la
tête de beyoncé sur corde en guerre